- You know one of my favorite
inspirational quotes is
you can't take the
elevator to success,
you have to take the stairs.
And so.
Watch out success, here I come.
FYI, I'm legally
obligated to tell you
that I am in no way a
certified life coach
but I plan on taking
night classes soon.
Woo hoo!
(laughs)
Look at this.
It's gonna take this lady a
long time to find success.
Maybe she should
take the elevator.
- I'm 78 ass hole.
- Hah.
Gotta take any
opportunity you can
to get a good butt blast.
(upbeat music)
One, two, three.
(breathing heavily)
Somebody say quick feet?
Woo hoo.
Five, six,
one handed.
(gasps)
Seven.
Wah, yes baby.
Well it's been a great warm up
but I'm sure ready to get the
real workout started, right?
(screams)
Ah, oh that's bone.
Hey guys.
Had a minor accident.
But hey guess what?
Like my mom said
when I was born,
there are no accidents.
Just challenges.
(groans)
So, full speed ahead.
Oh, excuse me sir.
How much further
is it to the top?
- Ma'am, you're bleeding, gross.
- Why'd he call me ma'am?
(groans)
A lot of people
take breaks, but,
sometimes life doesn't
allow for breaks.
(breathes heavily)
I'm just gonna
take a quick break.
I've got athletically
induced asthma and
(breathes heavily)
I ate Mexican pizza for lunch.
(groans)
I mean just look at this view.
So chill.
(breathes heavily)
(groans)
Ow.
- Move it you little twit.
- This is your Snapchat
life coach Molly Hawkey,
reminding you to never give up.
(upbeat music)
Just stay...
Hashtag blessed.